well there's a lot of questions still  circulating about  how new years will be celebrated in las  vegas this year  and this morning sheriff joe lombardo  spoke to our eight news now morning team  to anchor john langler about the plans  it's going to be different this year  there's no fireworks associated with new  year's eve along the strip  corridor i believe the plaza hotel  intends to do some  form or fashion of fireworks and within  their area in the downtown  area the sheriff went on to say there  will also be 100 fewer officers  there are also some road closure changes  las vegas boulevard from  spring mountain to reno boulevard by  mandalay bay will be closed to traffic  shutdowns should begin after 8 pm  denise